jours
dialogue de sourds entre le gouvernement
les fonctionnaires et les infirmières
négociations au point mort grève est
maintenue l'udf votera oui au référendum
caledonian les un bruit d'opposition
scandale à nantes mais si vous utilisez
pour expertises balistiques étaient des
textes de cadavres humains
le plus gros budget du cinéma français
six ans de préparation un film
époustouflant l'ours de jean jacques
annaud le tableau d'honneur de la
semaine c'est un grand maître il a 14
ans madame monsieur bonsoir avant de
décliner le quotidien un peu de recul et
un peu de vertige au fil du temps les
jours s'allongent
mais non me direz-vous nous allons vers
l'hiver pourtant la journée a augmenté
de 7 centièmes de seconde en quelques
4000 ans la découverte annoncée par des
scientifiques américains est d'autant
plus prodigieuses qu'elle s'appuie sur
les travaux que des astronomes chinois
ont réalisé il y a trois mille ans
patrick la notion du temps n'est
décidément pas une notion bien facile à
manier surtout quand comme moi on est en
équilibre en permanence plus jours en
retard
jamais en avance et pourtant de quoi
nous plaignons nous si aujourd'hui une
journée dure 24 heures figurez vous
qu'il y à quatre milliards d'années
qu'une journée ne durer que huit heures
bon tout ça selon le professeur karine
tang c'est de la faute de la terre elle
tourne d'accord mais de plus en plus
lentement
kevin l'a calculé cela en se basant sur
les comptes rendus des cultes solaire
observé par les astronomes chinois
depuis 3000 ans une de nos journées est
plus courte de deux centièmes de
secondes qu'à l'époque où charlemagne
inventé l'école kevin tang a aussi
déterminé que la lune s'éloigne de nous
elle est trois fois plus loin
aujourd'hui qu'il y à un milliard
d'années
pourquoi eh bien on ne sait pas très
exactement et puis désolé je ne peux pas
vous dire parce que de toute façon mon
temps de parole est écoulé en somme - la
terre va plus fort plus le temps va
moins vite à moins que ce ne soit
l'inversé
en tout cas puisque nous en sommes au
temps qui passe bon anniversaire
monsieur pérignon vous venez d'avoir 109
ans vous avez pris votre retraite en
vous étiez le chauffeur du maréchal
lyautey pendant la première
vous avez fait du vélo jusqu'à l'âge de
105 ans vous êtes bien sûr le doyen des
français
bravo phase 1 centime de plus pour les
fonctionnaires en 88 c'est la passe ce
soir dans les négociations salariales
dans la fonction publique le ministre
michel durafour qui rencontrait les
syndicats pour la deuxième fois n'a fait
aucune proposition pour une hausse d'ici
la fin de l'année
les syndicats maintiennent donc leur
appel à la grève pour le 20 octobre
claire chazal pour une fois la réunion
n'a duré qu'un quart d'heure constat de
désaccord total entre michel durafour
qui n'accorde toujours rien de plus faux
1988 et seulement 2 2% d'augmentation
salariale pour 89 et les syndicats de
fonctionnaires qui attendait au moins un
coup de pouce financier de 0 8% cette
année
le ministre a tenté en vain de calmer le
jeu je crois que les fonctionnaires
seront tout à fait conscient des
difficultés auxquelles se heurte le
gouvernement qu'ils savent en tout cas
qu'ils doivent savoir que nous avons le
souci de maintenir avec eux un dialogue
le gouvernement aujourd'hui ne nous a
fait aucune autre proposition
les six fédérations de fonctionnaires
confirme donc
l'appel à la grève pour le 20 et nous
appelons aujourd'hui les fonctionnaires
à y participer massivement
ainsi qu'aux manifestations qui auront
lieu dans tous les départements
nous sommes en colère parce que nous ne
pouvons pas accepter que les
fonctionnaires porte le chapeau les
déséquilibres économiques et du chômage
après les appels à la rigueur très ferme
de michel rocard hier soir les syndicats
ne se faisait guère d'illusions cette
fois c'est clair pour eux ils ne veulent
plus attendre comme le leur demande le
premier ministre au nom de la rigueur
économique et ils iront jusqu'au bout de
l'action la semaine prochaine pour
tester la résistance du gouvernement
c'est en effet une confirmation de plus
le gouvernement ne veut pas dérapé sur
le front des salaires comme je vous
l'annoncé hier soir michel rocard a bien
rencontré lui même la nuit dernière une
délégation des infirmières en grève mais
les 13 heures de négociations entre le
ministre de la santé
les syndicats d'un côté la coordination
de l'autre n'ont pas abouti
les infirmières demandent une
augmentation de 2
francs par mois le gouvernement en
proposant moyenne 600 francs dans les
hôpitaux en grève aujourd'hui c'était
l'effervescence des assemblées générales
christophe martet s'était décrit avant
même le vote
la grève continue dans les hôpitaux au
moins jusqu'à lundi
la méthode rocard n'a semble-t-il pas
convaincu les infirmières le soir quand
on l'entend informations 500 francs 600
francs est très enthousiaste et quand on
se rend compte le matin à ce que
facebook feuilles de paye on est déçus
ou par exemple ça pourrait faire grincer
rechange et 200 francs son salaire de
baggs et après des primes donc dans 15
ans pour commencer
autant sur la lassitude des infirmiers
répond fausse route
le gouvernement a tout de même besoin de
certains nous voir pour être élu au 6 1
on n'a pas fait partie des gens qui ont
voté contre eux aujourd'hui les autres
catégories personnel des laborantins aux
aides soignants frustré de jouer les
second rôles sont encore plus mobilisés
que les infirmières rien ne pourra
marcher si on n'est pas en forme si on
n'arrive pas à trouver un autre temps où
en dix ans le prix du bel au même prix
vous reconnu comme tout le monde par sa
femme de ménage ou rage hospitalier aux
infirmiers demain la coordination
nationale des infirmières se réunira et
même si la grève a été reconduite dans
les hôpitaux ou s'alignera sur sa
position
seule la cfdt estime ce soir que les
propositions du gouvernement sont plutôt
positives tout en maintenant quelques
points de désaccord perturbations sur
les lignes du rer aujourd'hui encore
avec les consignes de grève des
conducteurs autonomes et cgt mardi
prochain 18 octobre ce sera pire
le syndicat autonome de traction a
déposé un nouveau préavis
les nouvelles sont rares ce soir en
provenance d'alger ce vendredi jour de
prières devaient être le test de
l'accalmie qui règne en algérie depuis
que le président chadli semble avoir
pris la situation en main sur place à
alger
prudent le dreff et jean cornu la
mosquée de bab el-oued et pauvre et
surpeuplé à l'image du quartier qui
l'entourent la ferveur n'en n'est pas
moins forte particulièrement depuis
quelques jours ici l'autorité de l'imam
n'est pas seulement religieuse elle est
aussi et surtout moral après les émeutes
l'imam benaïche avait disparu cet après
midi 5000 fidèles attendaient son retour
l'une heures durant il a sermonné la
foule prêchant le retour au calme
les responsables religieux de la mosquée
ne souhaite pas nous
dire du brésil ont cependant affirmé
qu'ils allaient prier pour plus de
démocratie
de libertés publiques et par pitié mon
ti li ne nous présentait pas en france
comme des intégristes nous sommes pas
des fans agit simplement d musulmans
veulent prier
parmi ces hommes beaucoup ont participé
aux émeutes
il ne réclamait pas un pouvoir religieux
mais simplement de meilleures conditions
de vie
un semblant d'amélioration est
d'ailleurs apparu dans la ville depuis
quelques jours magasins d'alimentation
mieux achalandés prix contrôlés résultat
à l'exception de quelques chars
stationnés en des points stratégiques
la ville a retrouvé son visage normal ce
matin
bachir wyss le ministre de l'information
a présenté un bilan des manifestations
170 à 180 morts selon lui il a également
annoncé un plan de réforme en trois
points
mise en place d'un nouveau gouvernement
congrès du fln référendum mais dans les
rues d'alger
c'est une réforme de la vie quotidienne
qu'on attend plus de travail plus de
nourriture des lendemains qui chantent
la politique maintenant avec une
addition intéressante à la phraséologie
en cours le oui d'opposition c'est la
formule trouvée tout à l'heure par le
porte parole de l'udf
alain lamassoure le conseil national de
la confédération réuni ce matin s'est
prononcé en effet à la quasi unanimité
pour le oui au référendum calédonien oui
avec des nuances comme nous l'expliqué
olivier werner expression officielle et
publique de l'udf
blaise même sévère
oubliez les oui mais oui non les oui oui
non pas tout à fait valéry giscard
d'estaing perturbé par les états d'âme
des uns et des autres c'était fort c'est
d'obtenir de ses troupes udf une
discipline communauté l'edf préconise
donc le oui mais il y à l'art et la
manière de dire oui en souhaitant
répondre non tout en disant oui c'est le
rôle parfois ingrat du porte parole
mais le conseil national a renouvelé ses
réserves sur la procédure de référendum
non précédée du débat parlementaire qui
aurait été nécessaire
il a voté à une large majorité en faveur
du oui au référendum
ce we est assorti d'un commentaire fait
par le président de l'udf valéry giscard
d'estaing
la décision de l'udf s'applique
exclusivement à l'approbation de
l'accord sur la nouvelle calédonie afin
de donner sa chance à la réconciliation
des deux communautés
demain le rpr donnera sa position
définitive à son tour vis-à-vis du
référendum
contrairement à l'udf jacques chirac et
ses amis vont sans doute retenir l'idée
d'une non participation synonyme
d'abstention embarrasse et l annonce de
la tenue de ce référendum
l'opposition n'aura donc pas réussi à
accorder tout c'est violent les verts
eux se prononce pour le oui et
participeront activement à la campagne
qu'elle est denis fraternité c'est le
nom du comité de comédiens d'artistes et
d'universitaires qui ont décidé de faire
campagne pour le oui au référendum
on y trouve michel piccoli michel blanc
enrico macias alfred grosser que vous
voyez à la tribune mais aussi alain
delon et bien d'autres il y à au moins
deux manières d'apprécier la faire on
peut considérer qu'il s'agit d'un
ministre qui a maille à partir avec les
journalistes cela arrive on peut aussi
penser que la verve est une qualité qui
trouve ses limites quand on est au
gouvernement je vous le disais l'autre
soir michel charasse le ministre du
budget se félicitait en terme d'image et
les travail des douaniers dans cette
grosse affaire de banques et de drogue
ce soir alain juppé demande sa démission
entre temps une altercation avec deux
consoeurs de l'a5 jean-louis le saigne
assistait ce dès mercredi après midi
dans les couloirs de l'assemblée
nationale tous les journalistes
attendaient la sortie des députés mais
aussi des ministres quand soudain un
aparté qui n'en est pas un parce qu'il
est filmé
c'est très beau
elle est méfiant résonnent les âges la
jeunesse éclatante qui tue souvent pris
le dessus
wade leur compte
premièrement le ministre ne refuse pas
de répondre à l'interview sur la banque
qui a blanchi de l'argent provenant de
la vente de drogue
visiblement deuxièmement le ministre est
selon l'a5 furieux que cette réaction
fois diffusé à l'antenne
bizarre troisièmement même s'il est
réputé pour avoir son franc parler
michel charasse aurait traité toujours
selon l'a5 nos deux consoeurs de [ __ ]
alors qu'il leur a fait la bise quelques
heures auparavant curieux
quatrièmement le ministre encore selon
la 5 aurait menacé nathalie saint cricq
et anita auxerre de représailles par
contrôle fiscal interposés surprenant
affaire banale direz-vous seulement ce
soir alain juppé pour le rpr reprend la
balle au bond
ancien ministre du budget ils demandent
purement et simplement la démission de
son successeur comme si d'une petite
polémique
on voulait faire ce soir une affaire
d'état et le vocabulaire reste un geste
traditionnel de la part du ministre du
budget mais un geste est toujours
apprécié une grâce de trois jours pour
les contribuables qui devaient régler
l'heure à pau avant demain dernier délai
donc mardi prochain minuit
consigne a vu les harmonies
franco-allemand au pied de la colline
éternelle
le président mitterrand à déjeuner à
vézelay avec le chancelier kohl
au menu de cette rencontre informelle
mais aussi gastronomique que la visite
de la basilique
mais surtout le point des relations
est-ouest à dix jours du voyage à moscou
du chancelier allemand monsieur
mitterrand qui rencontrera à son tour le
numéro un soviétique dans un mois a
confirmé que mikhaïl gorbatchev sera
l'hôte de la france au début de l'année
prochaine
la campagne ne déchaîne pas les passions
mais l'élection aura bien lieu dans
trois semaines
aux etats unis les deux candidats à la
présidence george bush et michael
dukakis se sont affrontés hier soir dans
un deuxième débat télévisé dans la
manière plus que sur le fond le candidat
républicain favori des sondages semblent
l'avoir emporté paul nahon à guetter les
réactions de l'amérique profonde dans
une petite ville
au nord de l'état de new york jamais
aucun candidat à une élection
présidentielle n'est venu à des lay
petite ville de 3400 habitants perdue en
pleine campagne très loin du bruit et de
la fureur des grandes cités ici la
majorité républicaine en 1981 et 1984
ronald reagan a été élu et réélu très
largement pour regarder le second et
dernier débat nous avons réuni une
dizaine d'électeurs des républicains des
démocrates et des indécis la première
question de l'animateur a donné aussitôt
le ton de la confrontation et dans la
réponse des candidats
le fossé qui les sépare de vision de
l'amérique
les gouverneurs du kaki si votre femme
titi était assassiné violée seriez-vous
en faveur de la peine de mort non j'ai
toujours été contre la peine de mort
je pense qu'il y à d'autre moyen plus
efficace pour lutter contre la violence
j'estime que certains crimes sont si
terribles si brutale particulièrement le
meurtre d'officiers de police que moi je
suis en faveur de la peine de mort
pendant 90 minutes les deux candidats
ont passé en revue les grands problèmes
de l'amérique défense économie déficit
extérieur avortement sécurité sociale
chacun est resté sur ses positions et
les électeurs sur leur faim ces cils
george bush ne fait pas d'erreur si
aucune affaire n'éclate avant l'élection
il sera le prochain président des états
unis je n'ai pas trouvé que les
candidats ou ont qu à s'exprimer
s'exprimer sur le banc
oui et vous continuez à voter pour
dukakis oui mais je ne suis pas joyeuse
des sondages instantanés on donnait
george bush gagnant et mayuka qui s'est
bien comportée il semble quand même
qu'on s'achemine vers une victoire du
vice président des états unis le 8
novembre prochain à moins que d'ici là
les indécis fasse la différence en
faveur du gouverneur du massachusetts
un chiffre qui en dit long les
bookmakers britanniques grand
organisateur de paris donne bush
vainqueur à 1 contre 6 la lutte contre
la drogue bat son plein aux etats-unis
nouvelle et spectaculaire opération dans
20 états cette fois contre des
trafiquants jamaïcain rémy roche une
véritable opération commando durant 24
heures qui a conduit à l'interpellation
de 400 suspects appartenant au milieu
des trafiquants de drogue jamaïcain
ceux-ci qui contrôle le trafic du crack
cas redoutable dérivé de la cocaïne sont
soupçonnés de plus de 1400 meurtre
depuis quatre ans puissamment armés les
gangs jamaïcains sont également
impliqués dans le kidnapping l'extorsion
de fonds et le trafic d'armes
affrontement au pérou à l'occasion d'une
nouvelle journée de grève nationale la
police est intervenue durement alors que
les manifestants tentaient d'ériger des
barricades à lima la capitale
bilan des dizaines de blessés et des
centaines d'arrestations
la journée était organisée par la
principale centrale syndicale du pays
afin de protester contre le programme
d'austérité annoncées par le
gouvernement en vue de juguler
l'inflation qui est de l'ordre de 1000 %
l'explosion d'une voiture piégée à
beyrouth ouest trois morts 33 blessés
la machine infernale avait été placée à
proximité d'un marché et non loin d'un
poste de l'armée syrienne dont un soldat
a été tué l'attentât n'a pas été
revendiqué
il fait suite à une série d'attaqués
contre les militaires syriens
stationnées au liban depuis 20 mois
maurice papon ancien ministre à nouveau
inculpé de crimes contre l'humanité en
juillet dernier c'est ce qu'a affirmé
aujourd'hui l'un des avocats des parties
civiles à bordeaux la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel n'avait
apparemment communiqué sa décision car
l'intéressé
que ne ferait on pas pour les besoins de
l'enquêté a nantes un juge d'instruction
ait eu l'idée pour le moins bizarre et
scandaleuse de demander en guise de
cible pour une expertise balistique des
têtes de cadavres patrice voler un stand
de tir à l'abri des regards indiscrets
terrain militaire le 30 décembre 87 se
déroule ici dans la banlieue de nantes
une étrange expertises balistiques cinq
têtes humaines servent de cibles à des
bals de 11 43
l'armée française n'a pas de
responsabilité directe dans cette
affaire ce jour là elle avait loué le
stand de tir aucun militaire n'a
manipuler des armes
pour cet ex cette reconstitution
balistique
aucun militaire n'a manipulé les têtes
de cadavre et a fortiori aucun militaire
n'a pris de clichés photographiques
comme j'ai cru le lire ou l'entendre
la preuve ce cahier d'enregistrement en
face de la date une inscription crs 42
un crs moniteur de tir a donc utilisé le
temps réservé par sa compagnie pour
répondre à la réquisition d'un juge
d'instruction nantais se juge enquête
sur la sphère du tropique barre sa
tenancière a été assassiné en février 87
un seul indice une balle de 11 43 le
corps a disparu quelques mois plus tard
près d'angers les enquêteurs le retrouve
au fond d'un puits deux trous dans la
tête
difficile d'en déterminer la cause un
expert de la fac de médecine est alors
nommé il devra comparer ces trous avec
d'autres ceux de l' expertise balistique
justement les têtes provient
deux corps donnés à la science un
procédé rarissime pour ce type de
vérification
ces choses là ne sont pas inscrits dans
un cadre légal pas contre moi
personnellement j'aurais consulter je ne
sais pas si mon collègue de mon oncle a
fait fort et consulter le comité
d'éthique façon à se voir si cette
expérimentation était possible vous
n'êtes pas des problèmes d'ordre moreau
et seul le juge d'instruction chargé du
dossier au tribunal de nantes gilles
dubigeon pourrait expliquer ou justifier
ce choix
mais depuis le début de cette affaire il
se retranche derrière un argument
imparable
le secret de l'instruction accalmie sur
le sud-est contrairement ce que
prévoyait la météo les orages ont fait
place aujourd'hui à des pluies fines
le corps du jeune homme emporté mardi
soir par la crue de l'ardèche a été
retrouvé tout à l'heure dans le gard les
différents services de sécurité restent
en alerte mais à nîmes le plan orsec a
été levée hier soir
l'expédition sagarmatha que vous suivez
depuis plusieurs jours sur antenne 2
endeuillé ce matin l'everest actuel de
guide népalais l'eau des mares tristesse
tristesse et consternation aujourd'hui
au camp de base de l'expédition
sagarmatha 88,2 sherpa la caso nam et
passante en bar son frère ont trouvé la
mort hier à 8000 m très peu
d'explications sait seulement que vers
13 heures la kpa descendait du sommet en
compagnie de serge koenig
ils ont croisé passant vers huit mille
cinq cents mètres passant qui lui monte
pour essayer à son tour d'arriver en
haut lac tai reparti après on ne sait
plus leurs corps ont été retrouvés ce
matin environ 400 mètres plus bas
on suppose que les deux hommes étaient
dans un couloir et que le plus haut
entraîné l'autre dans sa chute les deux
corps ont été redescendus au camp de
base
quant à l'expédition elle est terminée
le soleil était radieux ce matin sur
paris
les partisans de la pyramide du louvre
aussi à commencer par le chef de l'état
qui a inauguré la cour napoléon au coeur
du louvre après quatre ans de travaux
elle est devenue l'une des plus belles
places piétonnes de l'europe
la pyramide du grand architecte chinois
yao ming pei y sera accessible un peu
plus tard j'en paye eu à peine inauguré
la cour napoléon a été adopté par les
parisiens un patient de s'approcher de
la pyramide
cette cour la plus grande d'europe sera
ouvert jour et nuit pas d'arbres mais
une composition minérale pavés en grès
et granit animé par l'eau des bassins et
le verre de la pyramide la cour et tout
laisse pas ça
aux pêcheurs
à fait plus sens propre en prendre le
clapier la villa pia message et qu'ils
sont beaux c'est tout autre symbole du
changement la plaque musée du loup qui a
remplacé ministère des finances au
dessus du passage richelieu devenu
l'accès principal au musée après la cour
napoléon
le chef de l'état a visité le dessous de
la pyramide et ses équipements
l'ensemble ne sera accessible au public
qu'en février 89 la seconde tranche des
travaux remodelage du musée et des
jardins et déjà commencé elle fera
danser tant du louvre intégré à la ville
le plus grand musée du monde
un ourson orphelin un grand ours
solitaire deux chasseurs dans la forêt
le point de vue des animaux c'est en
tout sobriété jean jacques annaud
françois restout sobriété avec beaucoup
de vérité que vous décrivez ainsi votre
film ce film que vous avez porté pendant
six ans que vous avez réalisé pendant
sept mois et qui s'appelle l'ours il
sort en salles mercredi prochain je vous
le dis tout de suite
tant pis pour la dithyrambe c'est un
film époustouflant
regardez
oh
jean jacques annaud pourquoi ce thème et
pourquoi ce héros pour la morale et pour
la tendresse un peu un peu c'est un
moyen merveilleux que d'aller au fond
des émotions que de partager les
émotions des animaux j'avais envie de
parler de ce qu'il ya de plus profond en
nous mêmes c'est à dire notre nos
réactions instinctives et quoi mieux que
qu'un jeune animal et quoi mieux qu'un
nourrisson pour exprimer ses instincts
new york est des humains
oui parce qu'on peut se laisser aller
plus loin c'est très difficile de ne pas
avoir de pudeur avec les hommes avec un
animal on peut le laisser vivre et le
regarder et s'émouvoir a vécu sans
aucune retenue mais le danger n'est t'il
pas de l'heure de leur prêter en fait
nos intentions nos sentiments même nos
regards
non non c'est parce que nous avons des
traitements et un comportement animal
que nous nous identifions il n'est pas
du tout nécessaire de dire un ours ont
fait comme moi marche
les oursons on passe leur temps debout
très souvent même chose pour les grands
jours ce sont des animaux très
entreprenant titre est très voisin de
nous dans le comportement
alors on connaît aussi votre goût pour
les défis cinématographiques et et
technique
le film a coûté 16 milliards de centimes
six heures d'efforts pourquoi pourquoi
si cher pourquoi si longtemps mais c'est
très difficile aujourd'hui il ya eu
tellement de films de fait c'est très
difficile de faire des images pas cher
qui se soit étonnante et
c'est aussi très difficile d'exporter
des images à bon marché
alors justement michel pascal va nous
montrer grâce au film du film réalisé
par michel barbeau les tours de force de
votre tournage regardez bien quelques
images extraites du film et maintenant
le travail des dresseurs pour obtenir
exactement la position voulue à l'écran
vraiment on forme une star avec 14
doublure et pas mal de biberons
filmé par michel barbeau voilà les
coulisses de cinq années de travail et
de patience
cinq mois de tournage avec beaucoup
d'émotion pour les 200 personnes
engagées dans l'aventuré
défiant les animaux les éléments et les
incidents les plus diverses
la caméra a sauvé de justesse dans un
torrent
une tempête de neige imprévus
ou encore une attaque surprise
d'abeilles mais à l'arrivée seul le
résultat compte
il est superbe
la seule victime des tournages
jean-jacques c'est vous vous avez été
blessé par un autre ce serait peut-être
pas la victime du film donc cet âge que
d'épisodes alors le plus difficile dans
ce film les ours ou les hommes à dans ce
film oui on les hommes ont été adorables
noms font les ours ont été très gentils
aussi on était en cage le soir et tout
le monde allait manger tranquille notre
prochain film
je ne sais pas je vais attendre de tenir
par la main celui là est le premier pays
en panique
vous avez beaucoup d'ours en peluche et
vous non mais j'espère que ses frères
parce que tu as fait pour le clip alors
en tout cas ne manquait pas de rendez
vous avec lourd sur antenne 2 chez
michel drucker dans champs elysées de ma
soi michel lui a vu l'ours ou plutôt les
ours les vrais et puis dimanche après
midi donc à 16h20 sur antenne 2 le film
sur le tournage du film prodigieux et
puis surtout précipitez-vous mercredi
vivent dans notre tableau d'honneur
comme tous les vendredis honneur à celui
ou à celle que l'actualité négligé qui
pourtant mérite un coup de projecteur
alors saluons le grand maître jeune
luthier joël bonsoir vous avez 15 ans et
vous venez de remporter le championnat
du monde junior des chèques en australie
la partie la plus difficile de votre
carrière
je pense que c'était la dernière ronde
un bulgare et il fallait à tout prix que
je gagne pour remporter le championnat
et ça s'est bien passé
lorsque vous ne dites pas c'est que non
seulement vous êtes le premier français
à avoir remporté ce championnat mais
aussi le plus jeune joueur
oui c'est vrai depuis la création d'une
championne du monde juniors je suis plus
jeunes jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant
alors votre héros c'est qui karpov et
kasparov
ben on sait aucun des 2 c fisher et
pourquoi c'est un américain qui a battu
les russes qui est arrivé très tôt sa
monnaie et c'est votre ambition
oui alors vous jouer aux échecs depuis
quel âge depuis la jeu enfin c'est à
dire que c'est ma mère qui m'a dit qu'il
m'avait appris de rajout de chacun à
quatre ans et n'offrant à 4 ans et
mais moi j'ai l'impression je te laisse
jouer alors vous êtes absolument
monomaniaque passionné d'échecs vous
pensé qu'à ça vous en plus vous
travaillez bien à l'école oh ça va à
l'école il faut bien lé temps en temps
quand mais pas plus que ça c'est pas ma
passion ceci dit ça pringé patrolin et
vous jouer aux échecs combien d'heures
par jour
c'est pas rien mais en général franco en
quatre soirs à joël bravo en tout cas et
comme souvent nous aurons peut-être un
très grand champion français du jeu
déchets les pronostics de pierrette brès
maintenant pour le tiercé demain à
auteuil
vous allez les découvrir sur votre écran
le
6 le cincle 1 le 4 le 2 le vin le 10 et
le 12
voilà à 22h50 henri sannier vous
présentera notre dernier journal demain
vous avez rendez vous pour l'information
avec daniel bilalian et bien sûr aussi à
13h15 avec bernard rapp
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal très
bonne soirée à lundi
ah ouais